[Music]
thank you all for joining us tonight
this is such a compelling and exciting
series and I can't wait to see how it
unfolds over the course do we have a
fire over the course of Eight Episodes
exactly uh but you know this all started
with a 2007 novel by Thomas melan of the
same name and Ron I was wondering if you
could tell us how this story first came
to you and about the Journey of getting
it made into the series sure um I read
Mr M's novel probably 11 years ago just
because I had read another novel of his
and thought I was a great writer and
just dove into it and I fell in love
with the the central relationship which
is Haw and Tim obviously and I really
liked uh their the fact that it was a
love story about people who were
basically not meant to be together that
they have very different worldviews and
it's that that great kind of sort of
love story of you know we keep trying to
get past our differences but we just
can't and that because it's a love story
that immediately has conflict in it and
then you know it's and um it you know
poses certain problems you know it's
period in terms of getting something
made as a television show it's period
and it's political and it was gay and so
I was just I after a few years I the
book was optioned for me by my managers
and after a few years I working on Ray
Donovan and then working on homeland I
was kind of giving up on it and I asked
this gentleman sitting here to my left
about five years four years or five I
think maybe that yeah uh to read the
book because I I wasn't sure and
basically what did you say Robbie um I
said uh I love it and if you don't do it
I'll do it um at Warner Brothers Without
Me yeah and that and sometimes a writer
needs that and so I went back to the
people I was working with and said I
wanted do this and then we brought Matt
on board and then made it beautiful and
um so I've read the book as well and the
you know the central relationship
between Hawk and Tim is very much the
Crux of the story amidst the lavender
scare and McCarthyism but the series
represents a an expansion of the world
in in many respects and Ron and Robbie I
was wondering if you could talk about
like what your goals were in expanding
this to series length and what you were
hoping to explore in that
way well it wasn't so much about the
length of it it was it was uh that
I there was a a preface of Mr malin's
book about five pages I think really
it's very short where we see Hawk uh
briefly in 1991 he's received a letter
that Tim has died not of AIDS of
something of cancer and I just thought
well that's very interesting to see hawk
in his 60-ish he's a father and a
grandfather by now we briefly meet his
wife and I I wanted to see that
character and then I wanted to see Tim
so I so I thought well what if I but the
AIDS crisis in the 80s and early 90s had
been one of the formative experiences of
my life so I thought no let's let's
let's let's address that and just seemed
there's this parallel between
McCarthyism in the a crisis you know in
one our government was uh in the
McCarthy era was actively persecuting
homosexuals in the AIDS crisis their
government was letting homosexuals die
from indifference to us and I thought
that's a great thing and then then I
started thinking well did they see each
other between the 50s and the 80s and
was just really having fun and Robbie
what uh story elements and threads of
this really drove you to it to threaten
Ron to make it Warner Brothers if he
didn't come on uh well I I knew nothing
about the lavender scare so um obviously
just reading the book it was that love
story set in the lavender scare where
you know like Ron said they were being
persecuted uh you know a love story set
where the stakes are so high um comes
with danger but also a lot of passion
you know when you finally get with your
lover um in your apartment or your home
when everything outside is so protected
and you keep everything so close can be
uh extremely passionate or aggressive
and all those things tons of emotions so
I uh I really you know just love the
book and and um and obviously I'm a huge
fan of Ron for of Ron's for a long time
so uh it was uh two perfect things I
would
say and speaking of expanding on the
book galani your character of Marcus
isn't in the book um and represents a
significant expansion in the story so I
was wondering when you read this not
having that text to go back on what was
the most exciting thing about the
trajectory of the character and what can
we expect more of this character without
any spoilers yeah I think for me I still
haven't read the book I don't think I
ever will read the book um I think it
wasn't useful to um unpacking the
experience of Marcus um I drew a lot
from my own experience um as a queer man
of color I feel like uh Ron was really
open to um expanding the world in a
complete honest way that felt um
viscerally charged and viscerally uh
full of a complex amount of emotions
that we still go through today um and so
I was really honored to bring Marcus to
life because I've never seen an every
man like him um portrayed television it
was really an
honor um and can I just have to say it's
such a thrill the SAG strike is over we
get to sit on stage with our thank you
sag aftera thank you for working so hard
on that deal heartbreaking for the last
few weeks to not be able to have this
voice be part of these conversations
such a thrill I'm honored thank you well
maybe you two could talk about the
impetus of marcus' storyline and and and
the process to bringing that into this
into the story well I I'm going to be
just perfectly blunt I was not I I I did
not want to W write a television show
with all white characters in that it was
going to be on air in 2023 and that
isn't being out of fear trying to be
politically correct because people know
me I don't try to be politically correct
and um have sometimes get in trouble uh
but um but it just felt morally and
moral imperative and but but I I
approach everything from a Storyteller
dramatist point of view and I just
thought well if it was kind of
fascinating and complex and dangerous to
be white and gay in the 50s what the
heck was it like to be black and gay in
the 50s and then to do a little bit of
research about the alleged
desegregation of DC in that era and to
also see that there were there was a a
really there were early uh pioneering
black journalists and the black
newspaper ERS were really really
thriving and there and so Marcus
everything in our show is meticulously
researched uh so Marcus is based on real
people and real journalists yeah of that
period I think one of the earliest
discussions that Ron and I had was that
we are not interested in retelling the
story of racism or homophobia really we
we we understand that that exist we're
interested in telling the story of
somebody that overcomes that how they
work through that how they process it
how they um are able to change the world
with it with the obstacles still in
place and so one of the we always talked
about Marcus um being active in in in
engaging and disarming the world rather
than just letting it beat on him and and
and falling submissive to it um and in a
way I think that draws parallels to Hawk
right as well um this character who is
willing to do anything to survive and so
we're like let's give Marcus that same
kind of strength um that same kind of
passion and drive well I would also say
and I'd love to hear that same flaw you
know that that you know is was important
to me and I I think that you embraced it
yeah and Robbie I think you saw it in
the wri is that that
uh that none of our characters are
innocent we we had a we had we had a lot
of rules in the writers room it's just
who I am and it on the set and on this
in both places uh one of the rules was
was there are no Noble victims we're not
telling a show about Noble victims who
are really decent people and they're
very moral and they're correct and
they're righteous but the world is bad
and they're struggling against the bad
world that to me that's melodrama that's
soap opera it doesn't interest me in the
least um but uh but you know you wonder
when you send the script out to actors
and I'm just curious like did you did
you I'm sorry I'm taking over no please
I told you I love it conversation but I
still think I'm the show in life yeah so
we're back on the set um did you like
the Marcus's was did marcus' flaw I mean
both you guys I'm kind of interested did
that like scare you in any way no I'm
always rooting for the anti-hero um as
Taylor Swift says um but um I think um I
actually was um excited by that the fact
is to reveal a necessary evil a truth
that exists within all of humans that
we're not perfect and we all make
decisions based on our need to survive
and sometimes that is not good quote
unquote whatever good means um it's
simply what must be done um and in a
world where segregation existed and
people were being eliminated from their
jobs because they were homosexual
because of who they loved um I can't
think I don't think we can judge whether
or not they're being good or bad they
were doing what they needed to
do yeah I would just say it's just much
it's so much more interesting when car
characters can be flawed you know
um I think you know obviously the the
hours and thousands and thousands of
millions of hours of like television
that you would say like straight
television where you have like all these
different characters and so you know in
this show and obviously it's not the
first gay show or first gay uh depiction
in media where gay characters are flawed
but like we really let them just be
human you know and again survival
Falling in Love protecting themselves
from falling in love doing things that
someone you know Twitter might think is
evil but like it's all just it's what I
think makes it relatable and not just a
gay show amongst many other things is
that like these they are human you know
they're not it's not them being gay or
St they're just like they have
complexities and they make bad decisions
good decisions and uh that to me is
really interesting I I I not to
criticize but sometimes you know you go
on Netflix and you watch something and
it's like everyone has to be good and
it's the exct that's like oh no this
character isn't likable and it's like
the amount of times I've heard that note
from people it's just like maybe they
shouldn't be like let them be human and
make mistakes and when you know Matt's a
good example when he does all these
things but you meet him in the 80s and
you see his eyes and you see his face
you know he's showing you that like okay
I've lived a life and the audience wants
to see what that life is and that's why
hopefully they stick they you know stay
with the show but I just you know Ron he
had many rules in the room but really I
I I find that to make sure these
characters are complex and not Noble and
they're not victims but they're they're
they're human which I really admire with
the show and I'm interested how the
process extends to folks like McCarthy
and Roy con who have been you know
depicted in popular culture before kind
of Larger than Life In terms we all know
like Roy K was depicted in angels in
America in a very Fantastical way
McCarthy and like the Muran candidate
was parody but like grounding them more
in reality for the series what was that
process like um
um well two of my writers are here and
actually one of our other cast members
are here actually Matt who plays David
shine Matt would you just
wave is he not here he's all the way in
the back and Ana Ana and Carl who in the
Ana is a producer and a writer and Carl
worked with us in the writers room and
so and I think about because Ana wrote
episode four that's going to be airing
next week which is where we get to know
McCarthy and shine even a little bit
better um you know we again I the there
could you could do the cartoon version
of McCarthy and con you know because
they're extreme characters they did a
lot of damage they are villains they're
bad people they did bad things but once
you reduce a character to that bad
person Trope I think that you're doing a
disservice to I just think it's bad art
so so M you know there's a complexity to
Roy con especially uh in his
relationship you were introduced to it
tonight you know in the episode with Roy
con's attachment and obsession with
David shine and uh that this is all real
historical and it's it's a love story
there's a way of seeing it as a love
story and somebody might say how dare
you and somebody did sort of somebody
not associated with the show I said that
to them and they cut me off and they
said oh he was a monster as if somehow
that's all you have to say about a
person and but Roy con was he was he was
a human being and his what he faced in
his life his inner demons created the
person who then performed a lot of evil
in the world and I think we wanted to we
were willing to explore that not to
excuse him or McCarthy's Behavior but to
make them make sure that they were not
stereotypes of a of a
villain you mentioned the meticulous
research that went behind this and like
there are so many elements even in the
first episode that just I like you we
talked about characters not being Noble
and like the element of gay people
informing on each other to save their
own jobs or something positive like the
the depiction of the the nightclub that
they all go to like these are all things
that like didn't ever cross my mind in
this era so I'm curious from any of you
are all of you like anything in your
research process that really surprised
you or you were really excited to to
depict um that might not have been in
the general Public's knowledge well I
and then something I think is really
important and that is that
people had
Joy they had joy in
Sex and as you can see from our point of
view they had hot
sex and you know just because one is
suffering social
oppression doesn't mean that you live
this joyless victimized life you know
Hawk enjoys life you know and so that's
what I think we wanted to make sure that
we just weren't doing this dreary thing
about people we're supposed to feel sad
for all the time and by the way the Cozy
Corner is real that there was a black
predominantly black gay bar near Howard
University Storm the singer stormy delar
who is lgbtq icon uh she was a drag King
and looked actually and sang very much
like our Chelsea does and by the way
that we have a sound track which
features uh this beautiful score in
Chelsea and so they I don't know if
stormmy ever performed at the Cozy
Corner but we just put her in there
because I wanted to see her so uh that's
again that's where we use you know
reality and we we twist a little
bit uh I me amongst all the research and
we had I think besides Ron Lewis our
researcher was the longest employee ever
for fellow Travelers by the way Robbie
co-wrote episode five with his sister uh
and it's a beautiful script thank you so
good
I uh
the I not to ruin anything because you
guys have to watch the episodes but
the the stuff that we found on McCarthy
you know especially that's in episode
three like that me I I had uh known
about McCarthy and then doing research
for this project and Ron sending me even
more stuff to read or to watch about
McCarthy like there's a lot of
interesting stuff but so I I'm trying to
give you guys information without giving
you a spoiler but what happens in
episode three is really all based off of
um you know research that we found like
in AFF David right that we found and an
accusation that we that was real so you
know the debate of whether like McCarthy
was a homosexual or a drunk or you know
just like an an assaulter um is Up For
Debate but but what we do in episode
three is all really based off research
so again I'm sorry I'm not trying to
give anything away but really when you
watch it like it's not something we just
we just made up and that to me um I know
if you've seen that was a surprise like
you know that people were actually made
real accusations against McCarthy um
because I didn't know about that in
history or my research yeah I sadly hate
to admit that as a
millennial uh lgbtq history started at
Stonewall for me and there's so much
more that happened before that and this
series really introduced me to all of
that and so I felt like I had to do a
really deep dive into history there was
a great book that came out right at the
time uh right before we started shooting
called Secret City um and I read it's
like a 600 page book but I read like 200
pages of it and I was like oh my God all
of this was happening before there's
even recorded history of it like like we
have there's no
um I had to read a book about um po
World War II life um about understanding
what it was like to be a black man
coming back to America having having
served in the war um and still finding
your way through segregation and getting
myself inside that mindset um was
extremely challenging and at times it
was just overbearing it'd be like this
is how these people just had to somehow
find Joy find love find excitement um
and still be passionate about life with
all this oppression um and so I learned
a a great deal a great great deal and
and one of the another one of our rules
was that we're not going to
approach our characters and the writing
the scenes with a 2022 2023 mindset
we're not going to say like well we want
to send out a message you can and so
let's change I I hate revisionist
history I think it's really dangerous
and boring and you know so we really
tried to be so sometimes a younger actor
or you know might say you know well that
you know my gay identity and IED say
stop right there there's no such thing
it's 1953 there's no gay identity MH you
know there are no gay characters you've
ever seen a movie or read a book or even
had a conversation about it yeah I was
wondering like if Jonathan approached
this character this staunch gay
Republican mccarthyite devout Catholic
like can I say anything from a modern
standpoint to to to go against like this
this role that is probably completely
anma to any gay person most gay people
that would be today right today yeah and
I actually have received some questions
about that why would he do that but if
you know anything about the 50s you know
first of all communism was real and so
and it was it cons if you're a devout
Catholic it is it's an atheist form of
uh philosophy of approaching life and so
you you would be drawn to something that
is Defending Your Faith and that's
what's really important I think in
acting and writing that you see things
from your character's points of view
without judgment and I think that's
that's what we did so you me go I was
going to say you did that and also you
had lots of drip in between too everyone
looks so sexy and cool and um you know
every shot is perfectly timed out and
framed and it makes it feel like you're
watching a dream even though some might
consider it a nightmare you
know so I think we have time for one or
two more and I want to you mentioned the
sex scenes we mentioned everybody
looking sexy um I mean the show's been
noted for the frankness of the sex
scenes what I appreciate I've seen a few
episodes now and you know there's this
kind of movement on the internet that
like are sex scenes really necessary do
they go too far and like I feel like
every sex scene in the show also has a
narrative purpose that it changes tones
in terms of tenderness or aggression or
the power dynamics so what was the
conversation like was there any
resistance to them being as Frank as
they were from Studio level or and why
was it important for you to have them as
Frank well the president of the studio
freem mantles Studio said let's make the
sex scenes between the guys so hot that
straight men watching them will want to
have gay
sex
work I M to that I don't know I haven't
no straight man that I know has come up
to me and said yeah hey I fooled around
with the guy last night because I saw
your show no way and if I by the way if
you run into one give me my number um
that's who I usually date
um too much too much information um
never too much but no we and and
Showtime said lean into the sex they
lean into it and so we were so that we
had that we all had but what's really
important was that every sex scene tells
is part of as part tells moves the story
forward so we don't say hey it's 20
minutes in let's take off the guy's
clothes because you know there was
nothing ever like that and we also had I
can't see my writers back there but we
also had a rule that there we would not
repeat any sexual position behavior and
there's so much sex that by the time we
got to episode eight right Ana uh we
were scratching our heads saying is
there an orifice left I like what like
like what like this went there that went
there what are we going to do and uh we
hold on episode 8 we figured it out
folks sex changes the temperature of
every relationship yeah always um and I
think what I really loved about the
series as a whole as we evolve in
talking about sex in between uh Hawk and
Tim and also sex between other
characters is that you see um quite a
stark difference um between physical
contact and emotional contact in between
sex and I I really really Champion both
of you for um depicting that on
television in a way that is so
Unapologetic and feels for me the first
time I've ever seen anything like
it and Ron's heard me say this before
but and I said it a little bit earlier
but
um when you are so guarded you know at
work you can't talk about you know who
you're in love with who you're going to
date with You' never been you know you
didn't go with you know you didn't go to
prom with your boyfriend you didn't like
there's just so many things that you
haven't experienced and you're you're
hiding from your co-workers and your
family and and just everyone you know
you're not holding your boyfriend's hand
like eventually when you do get behind
closed doors that can be extremely
passionate and so I think you really
feel that or I know I'm sure you guys
saw today you really feel that that
chemistry and that passion and tenacity
um in the sex scenes because again it's
like all held back and so finally when
that door is closed it's and the socks
are off you know what happens oh yeah
they about power the sex scenes are
about that was another rule every sex
scene is about
power so uh we have to wrap up but just
as a means of wrapping up um you know
there's the old saying to write about
the past to talk about the present and
I'm just curious from all of you how do
you feel this show coming out now at
this moment in our history is
particularly resonant to see this story
now in
20123 well you can't help but notice
that you know a show about Joe McCarthy
uh being aired at a time when we see
demagogues Rising all around us uh uh
not only United States but in Europe as
well that obviously there are parallels
and what de what a demagogues do they
create fear and division why I actually
have I would guess that Joe McCarthy has
really no problem with homosexuals at
all you know but he knew that if he
could scare you or scare you about
communism he had power over you and I
think that's being reflected in our
leaders right now that it's we they we
can't take them seriously about the
issues they care about the demagogic
ones they are trying to have power over
Us by making us fear each other and that
is um I think there is that
parallel yeah I mean I think it's in a
very eerie way very relevant to what's
going on I I forgot the guy's name
that's in Char the uh Republican that's
the head of the house what's it Jones
Johnson Johnson right so I'm like now
when I post up for fellow Travelers I
like tag him and I tag like Scott and I
tag like Ted Cruz and I tag like all
these people that say the craziest
things are believe in the craziest
things and it's just like whoo it's 2023
it feels like there's always people like
trying to take us back to the 50s so
when we set out to make this it wasn't
like it was relevant obviously because
Trump was like saying everything that he
was saying but you know it feels even
more relevant now because of who is and
as Ron said it's um trying to politicize
and and use fear as a tool to you know
win votes and win power take over the
show for
me from a 2023 Gaye feels at the same
time it's a celebration and at the same
time it's a call to Arms um I feel like
if I'm being very honest in my
generation I feel like a lot of people
are taking for granted the Liberties
they have received that they can get
married that they can have children that
they can um build a household together
those are now like oh yeah that's just
how life works now but at any moment
that could be taken away from you ripped
away from you and you're left with
living in the shadows and in secret like
this and so you watch something like
fellow Travelers and like I hope this is
educating an audience to understand how
important it is to stand up and protect
the love and the rights that we have
today um at the same time it's a
celebration because I've never seen
anything like this on television I've
never seen anything like this um we were
talking tonight dinner I've never seen a
character like Marcus um who is an every
man um that is simply
about his queerness is not his ATT the
the uh being queer is not a playable ad
adjective um and you see each of these
characters are queer but they're
actually fighting for something deeper
and more um substantial um to their
existence and so I just celebrate the
fact that we got to make this um I'm not
sure you know going forward in this
business what the future of queer
television looks like but I hope and
pray that it includes more shows like
fellow Travelers you're here well I want
to thank you all again for joining us
tonight thank you wonderful thank you
all for coming there's seven more
episodes to watch so please do
[Music]
it